It's great to welcome to the program today.
Edward Watts, who is both professor and chair
in the history department at the University
of California, San Diego.
He is also author of the book Mortal Republic
How Rome Fell into Tyranny, as well as the
upcoming book Rome's Eternal Decline and Fall,
available next year from Oxford University
Press.
It's so great to have you on, Edward.
Thank you, David.
I'm really excited to be here.
So increasingly, I'm hearing things from my
audience about, listen.
All great empires have fallen in history.
Sometimes they fall slowly.
The idea of the United States as this permanent
empire is a historical and you wouldn't even
necessarily know it while it's happening.
So maybe as an analogous situation, we can
start with with Rome.
Talk a little bit about how did Rome fall?
How long did it take and how noticeable was
it at the time?
Yeah, I mean, the interesting thing about
Rome is the transition from the republic to
the Empire is something that lasts nearly
100 years.
And it starts with a series of problems mainly
connected to wealth inequality that you see
emerging with the development of a financial
system in the second century B.C. and the
initials Faizan.
This was one where people were concerned about
the issue, but trusted the system to resolve
it.
And after about a generation, it became clear
the system was not effectively resolving this
issue.
And you started getting political conflict,
but it took another century before the system
completely collapsed.
And I think what you see in that is the system
continually reset itself over that time so
that there would be a crisis, people would
feel like the crisis passed and they would
assume that that was the end of it.
And this long, durable and really successful
Republican system had weathered the crisis
and would move on.
So at the time, if you were an average Roman
citizen and you recognized that maybe your
life wasn't that good, you saw inequality
much the way that inequality, inequality is
noticeable today.
You would not necessarily have said this.
This is part of the eventual downfall.
I think that that's right.
I think that when you're in a successful political
system that's been around for a very long
time.
The assumption is that that system has something
natural that makes it succeed.
And you don't assume that that system is flawed
or that system might be undergoing changes
that could completely undermine it.
And the other thing that's important is in
the Roman context, these crises would happen
maybe once a generation.
And so you would live through it and you would
assume that was that was bad.
But now things are back to normal and we can
move forward.
And it's only with the ability to see more
than a centuries sequence of change that we
can say, well, this is actually a very long
process of degeneration and decline.
But the people living through it didn't live
through that century.
And when they did experience these things,
they experienced them in real time.
And so something that happened 25 years ago
will feel very distant, even though as a historian,
we look at this and we say this is part of
a century long process.
And I think in the U.S., we can see something
very similar.
When did this process of political degeneration
start in the United States?
Did it start in the 60s?
Did it start in the 90s?
Did it start in 2016?
But we continually think these things reset.
And the reality is, of course, we might be
part of a process that started 60 years ago
and we just haven't noticed that we're in
the middle of something that will last a long
time.
This analogy, this idea is used very often
by technologists and futurists, which which,
you know, they they point out that when you
are in the middle of rapid technological change
on a day to day basis, it really doesn't feel
very fast then because of our lifespans and
the ways in which we interact with the world,
with technology is advancing more quickly
or less quickly.
It's not often that noticeable as you're living
through it.
And it seems that you're pointing out something
similar.
I think that that's exactly right.
We experience everything on a human level
in a day is 24 hours, just like it was in
the Roman period.
And so that means that change evolves.
It can evolve very rapidly or it can take
a long time.
And if it's taking a long time, we aren't
always noticing that process because our attention
shifts to something else.
And so I think the technological analogy is
a very good one, because we live with this
on a daily basis.
We experience it.
We interact with it.
And so the changes are things that we don't
necessarily recognize as part of a long process
that last decades or even a century when we
think about the United States.
Now, as with 330 million people, one of the
most populous countries in the world, although
certainly not not the most anymore.
Is there some historical analogy in terms
of the idea of the country separating into
smaller countries?
And this is something that my audience asks
frequently, typically for cultural reasons,
in the sense that, you know, when you look
at the Northeast compared to most of the states
in the mountain time zone, there are not only
there, not only very far when you look at,
you know, a continent the size of Europe,
these would be many, many countries away.
Culturally, there are significant differences
religiously when it comes to economics.
Is there any historical analogy we can look
at for the successful successful being the
key piece sort of sort of this assembly of
a larger country into component parts, or
is that something that historically has not
ever gone well?
The Roman Empire actually did this.
So in the later 4th century, the Roman Empire
devolved into a system of kind of central
administration was shared responsibility.
So empires were based in the West and based
in the east.
And generally speaking, that worked pretty
well in the fourth century.
But in 395, those territories separated and
generally speaking, that separation was something
that people acknowledged had happened.
But there was this understanding that the
east and the West were one imperial system.
Laws issued in the east were binding on the
West.
But eventually that stopped.
And as you move into the sixth century, there's
a Roman regime based in Italy that is effectively
separate from the east.
And there were conflicts eventually that developed,
but much longer.
It's a much longer process.
And the conflicts developed after almost a
half century of these sort of interactions
being peaceful and more or less.
Respectful.
And so you can see this, but I think the process
in Rome was one where the needs of the individual
regions were such that the central administration
couldn't effectively address all of the problems
across this vast territory.
And the Roman Empire was bigger than the United
States at that point.
And so I think that that would be the example
we might look at as you if you have different
regions with different needs, a central government
needs to be able to fairly address those challenges.
And if it can't, then there really is a need
for something that does more effectively address
regional challenges then a central administration
is capable of doing.
There are going to be people who listen to
this conversation and say that even though
in terms of the number of years in in terms
of sort of human history, the last few hundred
years of the United States are, ah, it's a
short period of time that such significant
changes have taken place technologically with
regard to sort of the state of homosapiens
on this planet, that looking at the fall of
Rome is simply not analogous to what we have
today, that we have, you know, of government
systems that are more developed with all sorts
of different mechanisms from executive orders,
the ability to print money, currency, treasury
interest did the full list of differences
and that what happened then could not happen
now in the same way.
What would you say to people who would assert
that?
I would say on some level that's correct.
On another level, I think we underestimate
what the Romans were able to do.
OK.
I'm sorry.
I would say that that's correct.
In you know, in large part because you're
exactly right.
The technological sophistication, the communication
mechanisms, the extent of what government
does.
All of these things.
Romans couldn't have even imagined.
You know, that's an empire that was governed
based on sending messages as fast as someone
could carry them.
And so you had a system that was based on
like it taking two weeks for you to hear what
happens in Egypt when you're based in Rome.
And so that's exactly right.
That there are really significant differences.
But there's also elements of how polities
come together and how people develop expectations
of what it means to be part of a political
system.
And in that sense, Rome can help us think
about some of the dynamics that we experience
and we see.
And so Rome, I think, offers us a lot of tools
to think with and to imagine what possibilities
might come out of the political challenges
we face.
I mean, so I agree with you.
Rome is not it's not the United States 1.0,
but Rome does offer us ways to think in in
a new manner about what could happen here
and to imagine possibilities that maybe are
most recent and maybe even the American historical
experience doesn't allow for us simply because
this historical experience is not long enough
to show some of these possibilities.
I wonder if another difference or I wonder
how relevant another difference might be that
the power of militaries and law enforcement
today in many countries is very different
in terms of both its capacity to repress certain
types of of of uprising as well as its centralization,
combined with the rapid spread of, you know,
you the when the George Floyd protests started,
they they almost started in tandem in cities
all across the country.
But they were really discreetly, separately
organized protests thanks to technology and
communication methods, something that, as
you point out, would have been very different
some time ago.
What do you think about that?
As you know, the power of military and law
enforcement in most Western democracies now
as something that would maybe prevent circumstances
from getting to a certain point.
I think that the thing this is a lesson from
Rome that I think is important to understand.
In Rome, you had say in the fourth century,
you had about 60 million people and perhaps
500000 soldiers.
And so it was a very heavily militarized society.
And the way that that society worked and the
way military was used to quell dissent was
symbolic shows of force.
Right.
You couldn't actually police this entire empire,
even with 500000 troops.
And so what you would do is you would basically
deploy troops to demonstrate that order and
law were still in place and that anarchy had
not kind of developed and that there wasn't
a kind of separation from the empire in a
particular region.
And I think that this is this is still a feature
of modern Western democracies.
Right.
I mean, law enforcement needs to law enforcement
does not have the capacity to be everywhere
at all times.
But I think that you're right, that one thing
that is different now is the the spread, the
rapid spread of protests and reactions to
stimuli.
This is something that, of course, couldn't
happen in the Roman Empire, because if something
happened in, say, Antioch in Syria, no one
in Italy would know about it for two weeks.
And so you wouldn't have had a spontaneous
protest that happened everywhere immediately
in response to something because news wouldn't
travel fast enough.
And so I think there you do have a very significant
difference that that presents a real challenge
administratively for a central government
that the Romans never had to deal with when
people were thinking now about 2020, when
people point to what they have observed in
the last four years of this administration
and then make can draw conclusions from that
about the direction of democracy or the state
of.
Of the United States is for years, even theoretically,
a long enough period of time to actually identify
significant changes in the state of democracy
or or is it simply too short a period of time?
I think we can see really significant changes
in the way that we do things and talk about
things in this country in the last four years.
The thing that's particularly alarming to
me is the rise of violent rhetoric and then
the fact that we now have violence spilling
out into the streets and in particular the
way that the.
Rhetoric that's coming from the White House
is matched by armed people going into the
streets to back up this way of thinking.
This is really different than anything we've
seen before in the United States, certainly
in the last 50 years.
And this is something that when this emerged
in Rome, that was impossible for the republic
to control.
There's a basic idea in any republic, I think,
but it's articulated very well by Romans that
a republic that is governed by law can be
it can endure forever in theory, but a republic
that's governed by violence is not a republic
at all because there's no consensus between
the people ruling and the people being ruled
that this is a lawful way of behaving.
And so violence, once it emerges into political
discourse, discussion and political debate,
is something that completely corrodes the
lawful ability for our society to make decisions.
And so I think that is something that's happened
in the last four years that is really, profoundly
dangerous and really alarming.
What should we be paying particular attention
to over the next?
For example, six weeks in terms of the election,
three months in terms of the transition period
and then the following four year presidential
term that will come after that?
I think that if there's anything that we need
to be particularly vigilant in controlling,
it's getting violence out of our political
sphere.
People protesting with weapons is not something
that democracies should be willing to tolerate.
It's really, really dangerous.
And the other thing that that you see in the
Roman period is when you start with that very
quickly, you start getting martyrs.
You know, people who are protesting with weapons
may not actually intend to hurt anybody.
It may just be sort of a symbolic display
of the capacity to be violent if necessary.
But protests are heated.
And when there's a political discussion and
people are armed, sometimes there is violence
that no one intended.
But as soon as you have martyrs, it's very,
very hard to walk back from that.
And it's very, very hard to remove violence
from a political environment when you have
people who have died for a cause.
And so this is, you know, as especially as
we're looking at the next six weeks and maybe
the next few months, we need to walk back
from that.
Everybody needs to walk back from that, because
if you do have the eruption of political violence
in the context of this election, it's going
to be very, very hard to control that and
very, very hard to get that out of the way.
We make political decisions in the future.
Yeah, it's a bell that's difficult to unring
once, once, once you've rung it.
We've been speaking with Edward Watts, who
is both professor of and chair of the history
department at UC San Diego.
The upcoming book is Rome's Eternal Decline
and Fall due out next year.
Really great having you on and I so appreciate
your time.
Thank you.